let's get back to the phones a lot of
people are holding let's start with our
caller from the 206 area code caller
from 206 go ahead hey David I'm calling
and I wanted to challenge some of what
you said about the Jill Stein recount
effort okay I don't mind that you've
taken a critical view on both her and
the recount effort but there are a few
things that I felt the need to point out
one is that you know the
characterization that the funds have
evaporated I found to be very unfair you
know even the article that you cited
acknowledges that these recounts are
very expensive you know it says that the
recount in Wisconsin and Michigan alone
cost two point three million dollars and
you know these are let's make sure we're
safety wise make sure I understand what
you're saying you're saying the recounts
if they happened would cost two point
three million dollars get the question
and really felt the need to if I can get
the race for a second let's see if I can
just get the question out are you saying
that a recounts that didn't happen would
have cost 2.3 million dollars no are you
saying that if I can just ask the full
question first and then I'll give you
the opportunity to answer right because
I want if we talk over each other we
won't get anywhere okay my question is
if the recounts had happened would it
have cost 2.3 million dollars or are you
saying that the effort so far to have a
recount which has not happened have cost
2.3 million dollars so that was
something I wanted to point out which
was that my understanding is that there
have been recounts in Michigan Wisconsin
and Nevada and efforts in a few other
states I think some of them have been
partial recounts and at least one of
them was a full recount and why is Jill
Stein doing recounts in stay
to where the recount couldn't possibly
have exposed that she won um well I mean
I don't think that she could have
possibly won right
I think the Green Party has a history of
caring about electoral integrity I care
about electoral integrity this was an
election where you had both major
parties claim some level of foul play
and I don't see anything wrong with
having a recount if only to assure
people that everything was above board
okay that's fair so a lot of the money
so after that story broke there were
some very general numbers provided as to
where 6/7 of that seven million dollars
have gone so let's see if you and I at
least agree on some of the facts six of
the seven million dollars that were
donated for the recounts have been spent
they are gone one way or the other do
you agree with that yeah you do and we
have not gotten any valuable recount
data whether or not there have been some
district level recounts in some states
the three key states that were
originally proposed as full recount
states we've gotten no meaningful data
one way or the other about flipped votes
or election tampering would you agree
with that as far as I know some of the
numbers have changed but no evidence of
election tampering okay so you would
agree also that the Stine campaign has
filed no Federal Elections reports on
that spending since September of 2017 do
you agree with that specific assertion
in the reporting I do not and the reason
is because and this was actually one of
the main reasons I felt the need to call
in you did a follow up segment a little
bit later I believe it was June 9th and
on June 5th The Daily Beast published a
follow-up article in which they
specified that she did file and at the
EPI
filing after your first segment but
before your follow-up segment and I
figured if you were going to do a
follow-up segment after the fact that
that the latest filings had been made
that it was something that should have
been mentioned okay yeah I didn't see
that I'll look into that and that so so
certainly you're not disagreeing that it
was accurate when I made the report
right no you know I'm not agreeing with
that all right so it seems really like
it's a matter of sort of degree because
what you're saying you agree that 6/7 of
the money has been spent you agree that
nothing of value in terms of data has
come out of whatever spending of the
money did take place and you agree that
my report that they had not filed
reports was accurate as of the time that
I made it so mostly you do agree with me
it sounds like well I agree with the
facts I think that it was the framing
that bothered me because I think that
the implication has been that there's
something really shady and dishonest
happening here and you know I think that
if the claim had been simply that this
was a waste of money
I wouldn't have really felt the need to
say anything but I just felt the need to
correct the record on a few facts and
challenge the framing a bit okay so I
don't actually know that you change you
corrected any of the facts all the only
fact that I think you've added is that
after my report there was other data but
that of course was in the future at the
time of my report so I'm not actually
sure of what facts have been changed but
I think your your main criticism is with
my opinion which is that right I mean
I've well I've not made it a secret that
I do think Jill Stein might be sketchy I
do find her presence at some of these
Russian state television events to be
odd I do find the Green Party's history
of dabbling with pseudoscience like
homeopathy and anti vaccine stuff to be
sketchy so yeah like big picture Europe
opinion and mine differ but as far as
the facts go we don't really seem to
have any major disagreements
that most of most of that you know I
would characterize as a difference of
opinion but you also made the assertion
in your original segment that there had
been no recounts and that just didn't
seem to be true to me
well whatever individual precinct level
recounts you're claiming there have been
there have certainly been no recounts of
the three states that the money was
originally being raised for you I mean
that you acknowledge right we've not
seen recounts and know it was Compton I
think had a full recount okay well I I
will look into that that's that's not
something I'm aware of I appreciate the
call I think you know listen I I don't
know what else to say
but I I appreciate that person calling
in and giving me their opinion